uh you and uh
first of all shout out to China Mac come
on because you guys had a very
interesting altercation you guys shot
the fair fade and now you guys are
[ __ ] making content together you you
inspired him to get his twitch uh his
streaming equipment going smart guy
um to me that's like a situation where
it's like this is how like
issues should be resolved in hip-hop
just in general man being men yeah like
you guys [ __ ] got it in kept it
moving and and I feel like people need
to see that right you know what I mean
and it's crazy that like a lot of people
praised that situation when it's not
really a big situation right it's like
okay [ __ ] got down they did they [ __ ]
and they did some normal [ __ ] it's some
normal [ __ ] well you know but it's like
you know people are so used to like okay
we're gonna slide on him we're gonna do
this we're gonna do that and it's like
listen you can have a dispute and you
know
you don't have to go down the blows all
the time let that be the last resort
that's the last resort Last Resort let
that be violence but just in case you
have a dispute with somebody you all can
sit there and patch that up and if it
can't be handled with words go ahead and
knuckle it up real quick and shake hands
and keep the [ __ ] pushing because you
know a situation like that China Mac is
is one of my dogs you can come to my
house whenever he wants to we about to
start filming other type of content you
know what I'm saying and doing [ __ ]
together so you know what I mean you
know he's killing it too his Mac eat
[ __ ] is amazing fire it's amazing yeah
when you uh do the food show with duno
uh how do you get like how do you guys
pick the restaurants like is it like
we we haven't done a Mexican spot let's
do a Mexican spot we haven't done a hot
chicken spot let's
shout out to S dog because he's been
helping us out a lot with that too and
[ __ ] us and going forward we about to
have a more um you guys got to go to
rafi's [ __ ] you just get the whole
Armenian [ __ ] experience that stop
put on for your [ __ ] people bro he
took me to he took me to a gang of spots
but now we're about to um we're about to
do things a little more differently
we're going to film everything way
um more structured because I feel like
by the time that we got to pick a place
we do it it takes too much time to
produce and I feel like if it was more
frequent then more people will be
watching it which is doing amazing don't
get me wrong sure but now we're going to
break it down into like seasons and then
take a whole week to film all the
content and spread that out and break it
down yeah because you guys drop what so
once a month maybe it's not even that
sometimes yeah it's not very consistent
no but sure you know we have the spots
it's just you know the editing team man
is is so much content that they have to
edit and they do on top of our [ __ ] but
every time we drop the views have been
amazing